which slope field is generated by the
differential equation the derivative of
Y with respect to X is equal to X minus
y and like always pause this video and
see if you can figure it out on your own
well the easiest way to think about a
slope field if I was if I needed to plot
this slope field by hand
I would sample a bunch of X&Y points and
then I would figure out what the
derivative would have to be at that
point and so what we can do here since
they've already drawn some candidate
slope fields for us is figure out what
we think the slope field should be at
some points and see which of these
diagrams these graphs or these slope
fields actually show that so let's let
me make a little table here so I'm going
to have I'm going to have X Y and then
the derivative of Y with respect to X
and we can do it at a bunch of values so
let's think about it let's think about
when we're at this point right over here
when X is 2 and Y is 2 when X is 2 and Y
is 2 the derivative of Y with respect to
X is going to be 2 minus 2 it's going to
be equal to 0 and just with that let's
see here this this slope on this slope
field does not look like it's 0 this
looks like it's negative 1 so already I
could rule this one out this slope right
over here looks like it's positive 1 so
I'll rule that out it's definitely not 0
this slope also looks like positive 1 so
I can rule that one out this slope at 2
comma 2 actually does look like a zero
so I'm liking this one right over here
this slope at 2 comma 2 looks larger
than 1 so I could rule that out so it
was that straightforward to deduce that
this this choice right over here is if
any of these are going to be the
accurate slope field it's this one but
just for kicks we could keep going to
verify that this is indeed the slope
field so let's think about what happens
when X is equal to 1 whenever X is equal
to Y you're going to get the derivative
equaling 0 and you see that here when
you at44 derivative equals 0 when it's
six-six derivative equals 0 at negative
2 negative 2 derivative equals 0 so that
feels good that this is the right slope
field and then we could pick other
arbitrary points let's say when X is 4 y
is 2
then the derivative here should be four
minus two which is going to be two so
when X is 4 y is 2 we do indeed see that
the slope field is indicating a slope
that looks like 2 right over here and if
it was the other way around when X is
when X is let's say X is negative 4 and
Y is negative 2 so negative 4 negative 2
well negative 4 minus negative 2 is
going to be negative 2 and you can see
that right over here negative 4 negative
2 you can see the slope right over here
it's a little harder to see looks like
negative 2 so once again using even just
this first 2 comma 2 coordinates we were
able to deduce that this was the choice
but it just continues to confirm our
original answer